in other videos we've already talked
about how classical greece has had an
immeasurable impact not just on western
civilization but on civilization as a
whole
in order to understand the period that
we call classical greece it's valuable
to place it in context on a timeline so
i have significant conflicts or events
that happened to the greek world on this
timeline especially in the 5th and 4th
centuries bce
in the beginning of the 5th century bce
you have the greco-persian wars where
the greek city-states are able to fend
off attack from the great persian empire
and then they go on the offensive but as
we exit the 5th century bce the
city-states start fighting amongst
themselves you have athens leading the
delian league in a fight against sparta
and their allies which significantly
weakens the city-states it ends with
athens losing but all of the city-states
have been weakened and it leaves them
open to be conquered by the macedonians
in particular philip of macedonia and
then his son alexander the great is able
to not just keep control of greece of
the city-states but conquer egypt and
persia and get all the way to modern-day
afghanistan and pakistan but after his
death you then have his successors and
greece falls under the antigone dynasty
but eventually as we get into the second
and first century bces it goes under
roman control
and we've talked about this classical
period all of the various contributions
we've talked about the contributions in
philosophy
from people like socrates and socrates
student plato and plato's student
aristotle
but there are also significant
contributions in mathematics you have
pythagoras who actually predates these
philosophers
and he's most famous especially to many
of us for his pythagorean theorem and a
lot of mathematics and the foundations
of a lot of geometry
but he and his followers they were
actually creating something of a
mysticism of a religion around
mathematics and even a philosophy that
would later influence some of the other
philosophers that we talk about
especially this ideal of ideal platonic
forms you can imagine if you're studying
perfect right triangles there's no such
thing as a perfect right triangle in the
universe these are ideas that we use in
geometry and other things in the
universe are really just approximations
of these but to appreciate the
philosophical side of pythagoras here
are some quotes from him or quotes
ascribed to him
there is geometry in the humming of the
strings there is music in the spacing of
the spheres
reason is immortal
all else
mortal and you'll see even in the 6th
century bce this thread of greek
thinking putting reason at a very high
level not just trying to explain
everything with pure mysticism although
pythagoras definitely was and
pythagoreanism was definitely about
mysticism but it was mysticism that at
the core had mathematics and geometry
but continuing on with significant
mathematical contributions from ancient
greece we have
euclid
we don't know all of the exact details
of his birth and his death but he is the
father of modern geometry and as you can
see in this map here he didn't live in
what we call greece proper today he
lived in alexandria a city established
by alexander the great and this is
during the hellenistic period where all
of the territory that had or most of the
territory that had been conquered by
alexander the great was still ruled by
his successors egypt was ruled by
ptolemy establishing the ptolemaic
dynasty in the time of euclid and euclid
lived in that great center of learning
in the arts alexandria which even exists
today
and he is most famous
for
his elements this is a much later
printing of his elements of euclid's
elements
but you would be amazed how much of
modern geometry has been described by
euclid even your geometry textbook can
trace it back directly to euclid's
elements abraham lincoln famously
learned every proof in euclid's elements
in order to fine-tune his mind so you
can really view euclid as the father of
geometry
but that's not all there are many other
contributors in philosophy in math and
this is just once again a sample of all
the folks who contributed
on the side of philosophy you have
xenophon who is another one of socrates
students in addition to plato and in
fact
the life of socrates we learn from the
writings of plato and xenophon xenophon
was also a historian who gave us some
accounts of the later peloponnesian war
you have the famous cynics
antisthenes and his student diogenes
diogenes famous for living in a barrel
in athens and somewhat insulting
alexander the great but these cynics
which the word is derived from being
dog-like these are people who were
philosophers who gave up the trappings
of materialism and caring frankly what
other people thought
as we go a little bit out of our
timeline right over here you have
archimedes one of the greatest
mathematicians and scientists of all
time
but you also have contributions in the
arts some of the most famous playwrights
of the ancient time
escalades sophocles euripides
aristophanes we might remember as being
a bit of a thorn in the side of socrates
he wrote about socrates but was more of
a parody you have contributions in
medicine the famous hippocrates the
hippocratic oath still has an influence
on modern medicine
you have some of the earliest what we
could say historians that we know of
herodotus famously giving us the
accounts we have of the greco-persian
wars a lot of what we even know about
the ancient persian empire you have
thucydides who gives us accounts of the
peloponnesian war along with xenophon
and so when you see
this density of
arts sciences learning in one place a
lot of this was centered in athens it
makes you wonder what was going on at
that time and historians do call the
period from when the athenians were able
to fend off
the persians all the way until the end
of the peloponnesian war as the golden
age of athens and for good reason look
at this flourishing of the arts and the
sciences that developed during that
period you might wonder what was
happening in terms of government
and government
of this period might be one of the
longest lasting influences as we exit
the 6th century bce in 507 you have
greek democracy taking root in athens in
fact the word democracy is a greek word
government by the people and shortly
after that
during the golden age of athens you
start having leadership by pericles
he was an orator he was a statesman he
was a general in this period right over
here that i have in orange often known
as the age of pericles he helped athens
invest significantly in the arts and in
architecture
some of the most iconic structures we
now associate with greece or ancient
greece were built during his time they
were promoted by him here you have a
picture of the acropolis which is this
rock outcropping which still exists in
athens as it likely looked during the
time of pericles during the golden age
of athens and you can see here in
particular the most famous structure the
parthenon a lot of which still stands
today was constructed under the rule of
pericles as i mentioned the greek
city-states get conquered by the
macedonians but after the death of
alexander the great falls under the
control of the antigonid dynasty but
eventually as we get into the second
century bce off of this timeline it
comes under roman control becomes part
of the roman empire
but the roman empire is itself
significantly influenced by greek
culture greek mathematics greek
architecture greek philosophy and in a
lot of ways the romans end up becoming
the caretakers of much of this culture
that we talk about in this video and
once you have the decline of the roman
empire especially the western roman
empire and europe enters into the middle
ages you have the islamic world that
acts as a bit of a bridge of this greek
culture into the european renaissance
and eventually the enlightenment and so
we can trace even our modern views of
science and philosophy all the way back
to these greeks
and so i'll leave you
with this quote
from the roman poet horus who wrote this
around the 1st century bce captive
greece took captive her fierce conqueror
and instilled her arts in rustic latium
or latium
and so what he's saying is even though
rome had conquered greece greece's
culture took captive her conqueror took
captive the roman culture instilled
greece's arts in the rustic latin world